تاثرت العلاقه بين السعوديه وايران بكثير
من التوتر المؤدي الى القطيعه والمصالحه
المؤديه الى الاتفاق عام واحد بعد وصول
الثوره الاسلاميه الى الحكم في طهران عام
79 توترت العلاقه بسبب الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه اتهمت ايران السعوديه بدعم صدام
حسين في الحرب لكن العلاقه لم تصل حد
القطيعه طيله سنوات الحرب الثمانيه انتهت
الحرب بقطيعه ايرانيه سعوديه عام 88 تسعه
اعوام من القطيعه انتهت بوصول محمد خاتمي
الى سده الحكم في طهران عماني فقط بعد ذلك
زار خاتم السعوديه عادت العلاقات عام 99
بعد عامين في 2001 تحسنت العلاقات
الثنائيه حتى توقيع اتفاق امني بين
الطرفين الهدف مكافحه الارهاب وتهريب
المخدرات ملفات اقليميه رسمت خطوط التوتر
من جديد من العراق وسوريا الى اليمن
ولبنان بعد 15 سنه تعرضت السعوديه في
طهران للهجوم فقررت الرياض قطع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه سنوات شد وجذب في العلاقه بين
الطرفين بدات بالهدوء مع تحركات الوساطات
الاخيره نجح العراق وعمان في عقد اجتماعات
مشتركه لمسؤولين الايرانيين والسعوديين
خلال العامين الماضيين توجت هذه اللقاءات
بتوقيع اتفاق عوده العلاقات في بيجين التي
استضافت مباحثات حاسمه نجحت بعد سبع سنوات
من القطيعه في العاشر من مارس عام 2023